welcome to the presentation of our work
titled diversity policy gradient for
sample efficient quality diversity
optimization in this presentation you
will learn about our algorithm called
qtpg which is at the frontier between
two family of algorithms namely quality
diversity and policy gradient methods
this work was done in collaboration with
the imperial college instadeep and
sorbonne university
first let me introduce some key concepts
of this paper
reinforcement learning is the problem
faced by an agent that must learn a
behavior through trial and error
interactions with an environment to
maximize obtained rewards
deep reinforcement learning and
especially policy gradient methods have
proven to be efficient to train large
neural controllers in continuous control
settings
they benefit from high sample efficiency
compared to evolutionary methods
this advantage is due to the fact that
they leverage information at the time
step level policy gradient methods
exploit the structure of the reward
function and also exploit the analytical
structure of the controller which allows
the sample complexity of these methods
to be independent of the parameter space
dimensionality
a major drawback of these methods is
their limited exploration mechanisms
that usually focus on exploring the
action space making the resolution of
highly deceptive problems very difficult
if not impossible
we will see what is a deceptive problem
in a minute
quality diversity is a new family of
optimization algorithms that aims at
searching for a collection of solutions
that are diverse and high performing at
the same time the objective is to cover
the range of possible solution types and
to return the best solution for each
type
quality diversity methods usually build
on black box optimization methods such
as evolutionary algorithms and have the
advantage of producing multiple working
alternatives when a single solution fail
additionally their explicit exploration
mechanisms make them very well suited to
tackle hard exploration problems
on the other hand they are usually
sample inefficient when compared to
reinforcement learning methods and
struggle to train large neural networks
that are needed in continuous control
tasks
in this work we will focus on three
environments that all exhibit strong
deceptiveness
point maze on the left of your screen is
a simple environment in which an agent
must find the exit of the maze the
reward function is the negative distance
between the agent and the exit of the
maze making it particularly difficult
for standard optimization methods that
do not extensively explore falling into
the local optimum of running into the
wall
at maze in the middle is a difficult
continuous control environment in which
an articulated ant robot needs to learn
to walk before finding the exit of the
maze
as in point maze this environment
present a strong local optimum
the last environment called antrap
rewards its agent proportionally to its
forward velocity as in point maze and
ant maze the set of walls in front of
the agent at the start of an episode
makes it very difficult for standard
optimization techniques such as policy
gradient methods to overpass the local
optimum
in this work we introduce the idea of a
diversity policy gradient that drives
solutions towards more diversity
the diversity policy gradient can be
used in combination with the standard
policy gradient to produce high
performing and diverse solutions
our algorithm called qdpg builds on map
elites and replace random diversity
search with diversity gradient updates
a full qdpg iteration consists of
solution selection in the map elites
grid then solution mutation which is
done half according to classical policy
gradient and half according to diversity
gradient
solution are then evaluated and added
back into the map elites grid if they
are novel or high performing
all encountered transitions are stored
into a replay buffer that is used to
train a diversity critic and a quality
critic from which gradients are derived
in qdpg diversity is thus brought by the
policy gradient updates and by the
structural pressure for diversity from
the map elites grid
to derive the diversity policy gradient
we first compute a diversity reward
similar to the standard reward provided
by the environment the diversity reward
is computed for each visited state based
on the distance between the considered
state and all previously visited states
by any solution evaluated so far the
idea is that a solution visiting novel
states that have not been seen so far
should be rewarded for its novelty
maximizing the diversity rewards in the
same manner as we maximize for the
standard rewards through the use of
diversity policy gradient updates will
induce an increase of diversity in the
population of solutions
a drawback from using the diversity
gradient is the need for defining state
descriptors that are used to compare
states and get a sense of proximity
between one state and another
here you can see qdpg in action on the
bottom row of the screen
our algorithm manages to solve all three
environments finding the exit on both
mazes and running fast in add trap by
first avoiding the walls
as a comparison the soft actor critic
agent which is a state-of-the-art
reinforcement learning algorithm does
not overcome any of the local optima in
all three environments
we compared qdpg with ablations and
policy gradients baselines in all
environments
results can be seen on the left of your
screen
even reinforcement learning agents that
implement intrinsic motivation fail to
solve ant maze and ant trap
we also compared qdpg to its
evolutionary competitors in ant maze
the ratio column compares the sample
efficiency of qdpg to that of
competitors
as you can see our algorithm is orders
of magnitude more sample efficient than
compared methods
to the best of our knowledge this work
is the first to introduce a diversity
gradient in combination to the
structural pressure from map elites to
implement divergent search
we believe that an interesting further
step would be to combine our diversity
component with genetic mutations to have
robust exploration in a wider range of
situations
thank you for listening to our
presentation